cuando tomó su primera dosis dlcd
Catherine emprendió lo que ella llama un
viaje esta madre de familia que ha hecho
terapia durante varias décadas sufre
desde la infancia de estrés
postraumático mejor registrados por
escrito los recuerdos de su experiencia
con esta sustancia alucinógena Viví la
subida del efecto LCD un poco como si
estuviera borracha cada vez más fuerte
hasta el momento en el que tuve la
impresión de desmayarme teniendo el
mismo tiempo paradójicamente la
sensación de que el trabajo más
importante estaba ocurriendo en ese
momento
tomó tres dosis de LCD con unos meses de
diferencia dice que los resultados se
manifestaron o muy rápido ya no me quedo
dándole vueltas a lo mismo siento mucho
más confianza en la vida y en el futuro
mientras que antes estaba muy ansiosa
siempre esperando la llegada a la
próxima catástrofe
era una actitud general
algo así en unos cuantos meses Me parece
increíble
Suiza es uno de los pocos a países del
mundo en haber vuelto a autorizar los
tratamientos con LCD esta sustancia
alucinógena fue descubierta en los años
a 1940 por el químico suizo Albert a
Hoffman y estaba precisamente destinada
a la investigación en el ámbito
psiquiátrico en Ginebra Catherine fue
atendida por los hospitales
universitarios la toma de LCD se hace
bajo supervisión y se acompaña de un
riguroso seguimiento terapéutico toman
la sustancia hacia las nueve de la
mañana y después pasan el día
siempre hay un médico aquí al lado que
supervisa
una centena de pacientes y han sido
tratados en este hospital por
depresiones o problemas de ansiedad la
sustancia actúa como un catalizador para
la psicoterapia según la psiquiatra Luis
abenz
algunos pacientes tienen muchas
dificultades para acceder a ciertas
emociones A ciertas partes de lo que han
vivido etcétera y en esos casos esto
puede facilitar el acceso y permite que
surjan otras pistas de trabajo
el LCD actúa sobre los receptores de la
serotonina y efectivamente produce
cambios de conectividad en el cerebro
según el jefe del servicio la mitad de
los pacientes obtienen un beneficio muy
importante el problema de los trastornos
psiquiátricos incluido el de la adicción
es que hay muy pocas opciones siempre se
hace lo mismo el objetivo de la
psicoterapia es ampliar esas
posibilidades y en ese punto los
psicodélicos Simplemente nos dan un
apoyo
para algo que tratamos de hacer en
psicoterapia en Suiza la investigación
médica sobre el LCD se acelera desde
hace una década Pero antes el LCD muy
popular en la contracultura de los años
kipis Fue noticia sobre todo por su uso
destinado A fines recreativos su
producción en los años 70 marcó el fin
aprovisional de esas investigaciones
pero el gran regreso del LCD de su
popularidad actual también ha llevado a
prácticas que se consideran
problemáticas
[Música]
uno apenas lo nota cuando lo toma pero
inmediatamente empecé a poner orden en
mi vida
en Alemania hay muchas personas como
Paul que quieren aprovechar los
beneficios de esta sustancia desde hace
unos años consume microdosis de LCD para
tratar Su trastorno bipolar según él
estas cantidades mínimas de LCD le han
permitido volver a sentirse bien algo
que los tratamientos a médicos
tradicionales no han logrado hacer
siempre tuve la impresión de que los
psicotrópicos me privaban de mis medios
y de mis capacidades pero con el lsd es
todo lo contrario digo no hay efectos
secundarios
como los cambios de humor o una
disminución del apetito para
automedicarse ponlo Necesita ir muy
lejos en internet a puede conseguir en
unos cuantos clics las sustancias
derivadas del LCD cuya venta Es legal en
Alemania
también se puede conseguir en esta
tienda bastante Popular en Berlín
los efectos son los mismos que los del
producto original
estos son los productos que mejor se
venden porque son los que tienen la
dosis más baja
este derivado del LCD no está prohibido
porque todavía no es considerado un
estupefaciente un vacío jurídico que
este joven comerciante ha sabido
explotar
según nuestro proveedor que es el único
que hace este producto
alemanes es el mayor mercado para los
derivados del lsd
pero el uso de estos productos por fuera
del contexto médico implica riesgos
importantes las sustancias psicodélicas
no son adictivas pero si se consumen por
cuenta propia sin acompañamiento pueden
desatar psicosis
este hospital Berlín es uno de los pocos
en tratar pacientes que han tenido malas
experiencias con alucinógenos tomislab
Magic alerta sobre un uso demasiado
ingenuo del LCD Ahora hay un verdadero
fenómeno de moda alrededor de estas
sustancias se suele decir que son
bastante mejores aunque no están
disponibles legalmente pero como es
posible conseguirlas con tanta facilidad
eso abre la vía a la automedicación
efectivamente en algunos casos sale muy
bien pero en otros puede terminar muy
mal
mientras la investigación sobre el lsd
retoma en Alemania y también en Francia
Los investigadores temen precisamente
que el uso descontrolado de esta
sustancia vuelva a ser contraproducente
para la ciencia a Costa de pacientes
como Cáceres que realmente sean
beneficiado de estos tratamientos cuando
se hacen bajo la supervisión adecuada